Alek skarlatos Spencer stone and Anthony
Sadler our three friends who halted
famously a terror attack on a French
train in 2015
likely saving many lives that got the
world's attention and also Hollywood's
but rather than have actors play the
three friends director Clint Eastwood
had them play themselves in the upcoming
film 1517 to Paris Alec Spencer and
Anthony join us tonight great to see you
guys so really the story just got more
amazing not only did you do this and you
know one of the one of the great good
deeds ever but you got a whole new
career side of it what was it like had
any of you acted before never not even a
school play well then to go from like
zero to Hollywood film directed by Clint
Eastwood's Connor it's a lot how did you
do it yeah we honestly just did it how
we did it the first time really that's
pretty much the only advice he gave us
was just to be ourselves and do it how
we did it
only Clint Eastwood could pull something
like this off so when he asked us he
gave us the confidence to attempt it so
we just had to try it yeah we just trust
him so much I mean we knew going into it
that he was gonna do the story justice
and just having him like Anthony said
have the confidence in us wet was all we
needed what is it it wasn't hard it was
fun I mean it was hard at first you're
getting used to it but I think we kind
of rhythm with it pretty quickly and we
actually have finished ahead of schedule
I believe he takes the way of shooting a
big picture motion picture off of you he
just keeps it real light and he's like
you're what your two friends just do
what you did and I'll capture the rest
and when Clint Eastwood says that you
got a cap you gotta trust him on that
yeah and you so what was it like filming
the pivotal scene in the movie and in
your lives on the train it was honestly
just a lot of fun I mean a lot of people
think it'd be traumatizing but luckily
we don't have PTSD I mean nobody died
that day on the train and I mean we just
got to hang out for like a week on a
train with the two best friends and
Clint Eastwood so you do it you get to
do it twice that's pretty cool and then
now it's more than just the headline
everybody gets to see actually what
happened how messy it was how crazy it
was and hopefully it inspires people to
maybe do something for situations I feel
like that's it that's it right there and
I'm not judging anyone I haven't been in
that kind of situation but you see a lot
of these things unfold and nobody does
that
what do you
that is people are scared and which we
were scared as well too I think the
unique thing about our situation is we
were just on a train and we had nowhere
to go so I know that all these
situations are different you know all
these different attacks and stuff like
that but hopefully this changes the
narrative a little bit and inspires
people out there that you know the
common man can do something if they find
themselves in the same situation yeah if
they're brave and what you guys are and
that's always the that's always the key
it's just any of you thought a scenario
like that through before you got on the
train if I'm ever in this situation
here's what I'm going to do actually
yeah we have we had talked about it I
mean numerous times beforehand I mean we
kind of played war growing up together
so we'd always ask each other like if a
guy comes in this room what are you
gonna do what was the saying I think
that was the biggest contributing factor
is our friendship going back so far and
we all knew we'd be on the same page or
something like that happened but you
actually did it
people just talked about it you did it
you're just as surprised you know yeah
given the opportunity and and that's
really it God well I'm glad Hollywood
came to memorialize this for all time
thank you guys for joining us tonight
they can have this man